[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi everyone uh i'm shaki goldwater i'm
the director of the simon institute for
theater computing
i'm delighted to have uh distinguished
guests with me today
and we're going to talk about a
fascinating subject which is
communication in non-humans and
non-mammal and
i'd like to start with introducing the
speakers in the panel
uh start with lilac villas from tel aviv
university
she's a professor and a pioneer in the
area of planned hearing and speaking
which is going to be the topic
of our little discussion today welcome
lilac and thanks for
joining in on friday night in israel uh
and our next speaker is
david gruber who is from professor
biology from the city university of new
york and he's also
an emerging explorer at the national
geographic society and our
last introduction is michael michael
bronstein
who is now a professor of machine
learning and pattern recognition at the
imperial college of london
he's also the head of the graph learning
research at twitter
and along with david and me he was also
a
radley fellow so we all met in bradley a
few years back
and michael is a researcher on
many many things have to do with machine
learning computer vision
and fascinating techniques apply to all
problems
and in particular the problem that is in
the topic today which is
how can we detect and understand
non-humans communicating so um
i guess a few we met the first time a
all of us on screen at a workshop that
we organized in the simons institute on
this topic
and all of you gave talks and also we
had talks about people talking about
elephant communication and how birds
flock together through some mechanism of
communication
and many other fascinating topics and i
guess maybe i'll start with
um with david uh who has kind of been
pushing us along at least
michael and i and tell us the story
about
how we got together and story behind the
workshop
and project that we're doing together
yeah sure sure thanks thanks shafi and
and thanks for the simon's institute for
hosting such a
such a fun symposium well you're really
the one who um
who started this and in one sense when
when i was
um when we were radcliffe fellows in
2017
2018 um it's a really beautiful program
where it brings together
50 50 different scientists or people
working in the humanities
and um and we all get an office there
and we work on our different projects
and one of the projects that i had been
working on
at the time was designing animal eye
cameras
so cameras that can see from the
perspective of
marine creatures and i had done this for
a shark and i was working on this with a
with a turtle and it was during the
radcliffe year that i had read a book
um called deep about sperm whales and
um in about this click communication and
about free divers
um that were interested in using their
holding their breath to be able to study
whale communication
and i was just starting to think about
sperm whales and had gotten a bunch of
sounds
and that was one one day when you would
come into my office and i was playing
you these sperm whale sounds and you
started asking a lot of questions
and at the same time you had organized a
a seminar at radcliffe uh it was like a
machine learning
i call it machine learning for dummies
because there was people that didn't
know about machine learning
but you brought amazing people uh
michael and people from mit that were
working in groups to kind of explain it
to the non-specialists and including
martha minow was there with us and
thinking of how to use
machine learning to to go through all
the law books and make um
make it possible to offer low-cost uh
high-end legal
advice but we all came with our
different ideas of how we could use
machine learning and it was so beautiful
to have some of the best people in the
world
explain it to us and kind of think about
our applications and then open up the
hood
of what's really underneath the hood of
machine learning and i think that was
really fascinating
and at one of the talks you would ask me
to play the
some whale sounds to the group and i had
my computer out and i took the computer
out and played
sperm well clicks but i just remember
that you know i was a little bit
embarrassed i almost felt like
i didn't even belong in the room and i
played the clicks and everyone kind of
listened intently
and i think it was michael and a few
other people that were like oh those are
very interesting
do both the males and females make those
clicks it's almost like a morse code
how many of these clicks do you have and
how much data is available
is there annotations could we use
supervised or non-supervised
and that set me on a journey to go back
within my marine biology community and
find out those answers
and that led to one of our first studies
where um we replied advanced machine
learning on sperm well clicks and
michael could talk about that so
that's really the genesis of what this
workshop and how we all came together
and then that led to submitting a
proposal for
for to to do a large-scale project and
and that we're just super thankful that
that got ted audacious funding
which is just starting so this is a
brand new project that's
that's at it's like most baby stages
right now but it'll be five years
and there's about 20 scientists involved
and we are going to even take
two years to be establishing our core
whale listening station that will cover
20 kilometers
and allow us to hear which whale is
talking to which
24 7 and then start building up the data
sets using a combination of this core
system and
tags that are going the whales to build
up a rich data set
in the in the millions or billions that
we could then
um apply some of these advanced tools
and
that's where where um
where i guess it comes into thinking of
how we would pipeline
all this information um efficiently
into something like a twitter or a
google
and allow it to to apply these
industrial processes
to an animal like a whale or or a plant
yeah in fact michael maybe you could
tell us more about the study project and
uh your role in it
i mean maybe it was machine learning for
dummies but you certainly
were an expert um and uh
yeah me too but michael was actually uh
sitting there nodding when
everybody was explaining and he could
explain to us further so could you tell
us a little bit about the project
sure so i think well yeah so um i think
well as as david mentioned uh it was
really
him bringing these uh these uh these
whale sounds and
sharpie organizing the the machine
learning seminar maybe
not necessarily for dummies uh but
somehow it brought us all together
and uh trying to look from a different
perspective
on uh something that has been attempted
um in the past
so i would say that in brief project
settings
now a multi-disciplinary collaboration
that attempts to exploit
modern machine learning technology to
understand the communication of sperm
whales
and um i would not use the term language
because it's
maybe a little bit controversial
especially in the linguists
and actually recently i was reading a
paper
uh that kevin uh our linguist
the project study team suggested it's a
seminal paper on the faculty of language
by hauser chomsky and speech and
it starts with this um analogy or
uh this illustration that if emotion
landed on our planet
it would be struck by the uh that we all
look the same the remarkable similarity
among all versus living creatures uh
essentially all life we know is
based on proteins that are encoded in uh
in dna
that can create a practically limitless
variety of species and
individual organisms and yet this kind
of
common pattern or common blueprints is
completely absent
when talking about communication so if
you look at different animals they
communicate in completely different ways
and actually this
martian would would immediately see that
humans are really set apart in the way
that they communicate the
complexity the hierarchy generative
recursive
practically unbounded uh expressiveness
of our language
and whether animals uh have anything
similar to human language
basically basically whether animal
communication
can be called the language is more or
less disputed so some people say that
yes animals have communication that
that can be called the language some
people say that only only humans have
language
and we are obviously not the first of
them to try to understand
uh animal communication and uh basically
you can you can wonder what why would we
believe why would be uh
the first ones maybe to succeed really
to understand and hopefully talk back to
the whales
and uh this is what i tried to
articulate in the
in the talk in the in the simon's
workshop is uh
basically doing some some decisions some
choices
and this is the choice of the species
the technology we will use
and also these uh multi-separate the in
the special team
that that david has assembled
so these pieces we chose the sperm
whales obviously
there are many reasons uh besides just
uh
having uh uh listen to the sounds of
these of these animals
in the in the in the seminar and then i
also remember uh
one cool evening when david uh uh forced
us to
to watch the the star trek movie where
there is this episode where
uh uh the starship enterprise uh
travels back uh uh in in the past to
save uh to say
whales so these are um seriously
speaking these are mammals
with the largest brain in the world
they're several times bigger than the
human brain
and they have a lot of similarities in
let's say social organization to humans
and probably most importantly and this
is really what david mentioned
is they communicate in something that
sounds very much like morse code so it's
a sequence of clicks that travel long
distance under water
and they are organized into very highly
structured patterns
that biologists call colors so it's
apparently a very
complex communication system with a
rather simple encoding which is
very appealing for the analysis right
because it's just just clicks
with intervals between them at least in
some first order approximation
the problem is of course that we know
very little about whales
because they live under water they dive
very deeply where humans can
hardly descend and even observing these
animals
has been rather challenging what is
what plays to our favor is that their
communication is primarily acoustic so
one of
the goals of project city is building
technology
and devices for recording the
communication and behavioral information
and we want to do it over a large area
in dominica and also
over long time span because most of
these observations have been pretty
short
and localized and i would say that even
this is rather
unprecedented because well likely to end
up with probably the largest
civil uh underwater recording
installation in the world maybe
that is only dwarfed by by some military
submarine tracking devices
so the second thing is that now probably
for the first time we have
uh the technology the capability to
process and analyze
the massive amounts of bio-acoustic data
that that project setting will generate
from these sensors and uh deep learning
is one such technology so one of the
uh prominent topics in the workshop was
the use of modern machine learning
technologies so it is
the the kind of technology that has
revamped the way that we approach
natural language processing
it also created a multi-billion industry
in the way so if you think of google
translate or
siri that you use on your iphone uh it
is all powered by
by deep learning so for example modern
nlp methods uh
allow to learn language models from
scratch using unannotated data
and even if you think of machine
translation which has
traditionally required a parallel corpus
of text in different languages
kind of rosetta stone can now since
couple of years
be done in totally unsupervised way
and finally the third component is uh
really the brilliant
multi-disciplinary team and you can
think that building the hardware that
will allow to record the whales to
process their bioacoustic data to train
machine learning models
and interpret these results requires uh
synthesis of of skills and a team of
biologists computer scientists linguists
experts in marine operation because it's
completely non-trivial to deploy and
operate such devices underwater
and this is probably what is so special
about this project
and i should say that frankly i feel
really humbled to work with
such an incredible brain power that
david has managed to
assemble together and for me this is
really once in a lifetime project the
moonshot that that
probably doesn't happen in a career of a
scientist so i'm really
uh very proud to be to be part of it
and maybe taking a step back and
thinking of the the the longer impact of
project city
that goes beyond what probably we can
even imagine now in
in the wilderness of our fantasies
and excuse me for maybe a little bit
arrogant
analogy if you think of underground
breaking large scale scientific
endeavors such as
let's say the human genome project it
eventually costs
more than two billion dollars to
sequence the dna of a human being for
the first time
so if you think of the length of the dna
it's more than one dollar per nucleotide
and uh you may wonder why uh was it such
a big deal
because it didn't really answer a
specific question but uh the
the the the groundbreaking impact was
really
creating the technological capability
and laying the foundations to
enable uh investigation of new questions
that continuously arise from
these data reach sources and thanks to
this technology two
two decades later now we have previously
unbelievable capabilities where in
medicine and biology and
uh really the sky is the limit so i
think the long-term impact of project
seti
is to try to deliver these technological
foundations that will enable
the study of non-human species
communication
we will start with firm whales but maybe
it will
eventually diverge into other marine
mammals
and animals in general and maybe it's
not only us but
will encourage the academic
research community to do it
i just want to pick up on something you
you said
[Music]
obviously people when they talk about
machine learning they talk about
application to
medicine to advertising you know
quite a difference but in any case they
talk always about applications that
have some sort of besides uh
global important topics they have profit
you know
and what's beautiful to me about this
project is that this is really about
fundamental science understanding
how animals communicate how this other
form of
life manages to accomplish the goals
that they accomplish
is is beyond sort of uh you know an
interest group of one or another there's
some
fundamental thing that we all want us to
stand i think even as children
you have such incredible curiosity about
these animals around you
and what are they saying are they saying
anything so to me
you said about moonshot it's like this
one project that
it would really advance the world in my
opinion it's in its most basic form the
knowledge of the world in its most
specific form
under the assumption that we're
successful we're not the first to try
but we do have a host of new
techniques to our disposal because the
obvious questions for some people is
what's new why are you guys going to
break this
enigma that has fascinated people for
for centuries and i think uh between
what all of you have said what's new is
that there are these tools out there and
there's ways to get
data to collect data and possibly
by collecting vast amounts of data and
applying the
tools that have been developed which are
data driven
we will find out something new we will
be able to crack this
code yeah i think it's about organizing
us right we're organizing from the
beginning
so a lot of the times i work on projects
where you're just given data sets
and you you try to make sense of the
data sets and three different people
collected them and
you'll find um you know some bias in
between the different data sets
so with this is like thinking having
having people like you and michael from
the really ground
before we even start collecting the data
to even think about how we will collect
this data
um because you could collect in you know
you could collect
infinite amounts of data but it's what
are the where and how do we collect it
and and then how do we funnel that
together and and i think that's one of
the really exciting things of
of piecing this this big puzzle together
but thinking from scratch
and and then watching as we go
from year one to we have five years of
funding to
to see where we get which i want to
bring discussion over to lilac oh i also
met sort of accidentally
not in yet radcliffe but in tel aviv
with another friend and she was
telling me about this research that she
was doing about uh plants
that and the fact that the plants can
actually hear us
and i was telling her about the whales
and it turns out
that we have a lot more in common than
we
uh originally thought so this is you
know like
wow yet another dimension can you tell
us a little bit about your work on
plants and
hearing talking
so i think um the question of
animal communication is uh
already quite controversial and then we
have
an even more surprising question
of plant communication and in particular
we work on plant acoustic communication
so this is a work that is
still in the first stages
but the first things that we know is
that plants can hear
in the sense that they can respond
to sounds they can respond rapidly in a
relevant way
like if we record
the sound of one flying b
and play this sound to a flower in this
case the evening primrose
then within three minutes the flower
can produce nectar that is significantly
sweeter
that means that there is communication
or at least response of the flower
to the sound emitted by the bee
and we definitely expect this
to occur out of the lab and we
also if it works for this flower it also
probably works
for other flowers and if
plants can respond to sound since there
is the potential
that they can respond to all sorts of
sounds
that are relevant to them that was the
first step
that we discussed long long ago
and then the question and that we are
still uh
wondering about this can plants
respond to the sounds of other plants
and do plants emit sounds that other
organisms
can hear and respond to
and here um this was really
more similar to the real example than we
expect because we discovered that plants
actually
emit sounds clicks
that we can record ultrasonic clicks
and that they do so particularly in
times of stress
and then we wanted to say something
about these clicks
and and to see if we can
separate them both from other noises and
between
different sounds emitted by
different species of plants different
conditions of the plants
and here we found ourselves
with deep learning
techniques and
constructing classifiers that
happen to be quite similar to the
whale case
and we found that indeed
we can separate very effectively
from the sounds of the plant and the
sounds of the plants from
other noises in the greenhouse and also
between sounds of different plants
different plant species and sounds of
the same plant species under different
conditions
um and now the most exciting part
is still open so in contrast
with the animal case where we know that
there is communication
and we want to understand what exactly
they are saying
but the difficulty is
recording them effectively and following
them etc
with the plant they stay in the same
place they make a life
very easy in that sense but we are not
yet
sure if there is communication
do other plants respond to these sounds
and another option that we think is
might be exciting
is if other organisms
respond to these sounds once we know
that the sounds are out there
in the world and they do carry
information
because we can identify
like a drying tomato plant according to
its sounds only
then other animals that are capable of
hearing these sounds
might do something about it
remember from your talk also during the
workshop
that you mentioned i think it's in
connection with your
work on evolution earlier that you felt
that the way the
land has developed in some cases was
possibly because they want to emit
certain sounds which is something that's
probably completely new as a
as a reason for why would a plan take a
particular shape that might look like uh
you know a broadcast instrument or a
receiver
i thought that was you know fascinating
different line of trying to explain why
a plan looks like it does is there
anything you want to say about it
so i think this is one of my favorite
parts
because when we think of flowers
of flowers that are large and colorful
than we think that they invest
in catching the eye of the pollinator
and that's definitely part of the of the
business
but then as
the size of the flower and especially
the structure of the flower
also affect its ability to be an
effective
ear in that sense it is not exactly like
an ear in any other sense
but this is the part of the plant
where airborne sounds turn into
vibration of the tissue
and then now when we see a flowers it is
large
and has a roundish
shape and
it might have been under 2 two
regimes of selection one selection
acting on how it would
look to the pollinators and another
acting on how good it is as an ear
if it is a more effective year then
it can respond
more effectively to the pollinators when
they arrive
and offer them improve reward
if the pollinator is happier it would
look for a similar plant
flowers afterwards and so
it might be that when we walk in the
field
it is all full of ears in the different
sizes and shapes and
this should still be explored how well
do different flowers
here but it seems that some selection on
hearing ability
was definitely affecting
shapes of some of the flowers
fascinating another thing i guess i
remember you just actually touched on it
when you were speaking
is this issue of stress that possibly uh
plants emit
stress uh sounds when they're stressed
before you can actually see that
visually so possibly listening to them
we could have earlier indicators if the
plants are being stressed or not watered
enough and so forth
uh yeah so so we tested
uh two two types of stress we did most
of our work on
tomato and tobacco plants and
uh these plants when they are happy
in the lab when they are
watered enough and they don't make
almost any sounds
they start emitting sounds when things
go wrong
and we tested one case when
they experience dehydration
and another case where um
we cut the
stem with scissors so
in books case they emitted sounds
the first case was more interesting for
us
first because the aeration is always a
problem how much
water do we need to use to water the
fields and not to use
too much and it turns out
that when we stop watering
the tomatoes already in the second day
they start emitting sounds but they
still look
healthy and green and so this suggests
but this needs further exploration
that we might in some cases have
indications
that plants need watering
even before uh damage had occurred
maybe that some of the sounds and are
emitted already at the first stages
of the administration
so i you know it's fascinating also and
i was wondering if anybody wants to
chime in on that
um is that it seems like we're using
similar tools
uh when we are analyzing sounds between
whales or sperm whales sounds between
plants which is sort of the
basic machine learning uh neural nets
and deep nets and so forth
so there could be two explanations to
this one is that maybe there is a
um you know a kit or a tool kit
which can be applied more generally to
any form of communication or that we're
just
scratching the surface whereas beginning
and we only have very primitive
means and that's what we're applying but
there needs to be much more specialized
tools there can be more specialized
tools for each one of this
species so anybody wants to weigh in on
this
i would welcome to hear some thoughts
i i guess um you know thinking about i
in my in my career i've studied many
different animals all the way now
from bacteria to sperm whales
and i guess the one thing that's
constant with anything that i study
is that i'm never underwhelmed at
any form of life you know on this planet
like it's always interesting
when we dig deeper into something
there's always like really amazing
secrets
that um that we can find so what's
really fascinating i think to this
project
is that in first
i was i was kind of trying to crossing
it's really about crossing disciplines
because by shafi you having that machine
learning workshop
was it was it was opening up a new set
of tools
that as someone who studies biology and
looking at communication
that euron the work is was so advanced
that it hadn't really trickled into
many different fields of animal behavior
and i think that by putting together
this um this workshop we went and we
found um you know joyce poole and
elephant singing outcome plants
and yoseovo on bats and we
highlighted some people that were doing
really excellent work
and it turns out that we're using
similar tools
but maybe in different ways and i think
michael could also probably talk about
too and
in the sperm whale community some of the
techniques might be
things that had been done 10 15 years
ago in other in other fields so
it's not like everybody's moving at the
same pace
and i think um one of the beauties of
this seminar was really to bring
together
people that were working in all
different kinds of animals
and put them in the same room because we
don't often go in the same room
um we knock we probably don't come
across the whale crowd as much or the
bat
crowd or the elephant crowd but there
are all these similarities and i think
the the moment that we're at with
machine learning
um it may not have been here for that
long
where there's the really possibility to
apply these advanced tools and really
advance these fields
so um i think that's kind of one of the
beautiful things of like
putting this conference together putting
these people together
realizing that we're all addressing
similar problems of um where's the sound
coming from um how to identify that
and um and then how to kind of walk
through
um the the measuring
the communication of the animals into
making sense and i
i think that's where the the beauty of
like the unsupervised learning is
is it comes in um and offers so much
power to find patterns that we might not
have seen before
michael what do you think about this
idea that um that to every uh
to a hammer everything looks like a nail
so in other words we've got this hammer
of
neural nets and we're just gonna uh
apply it everywhere and we will get
results just because
the results are there to be had or or do
we
or would you say that we need to develop
some more specialized tools
well i'm very i very much agree to this
uh this uh maxim
that as you're saying once we have a
camera that
indeed everything looks like uh like a
nail and indeed
neural network sleep learning uh methods
have been uh maybe a little bit
overhyped
but i think what what um what is common
in these problems or in general
applications where neural networks are
applied
or machine learning methods are applied
is that they
uh there is large uh quantities of data
and this is really fundamental
difference that that happened
uh probably over the past decade or
two that that we started in many fields
of science
which previously were mostly
observational type of science including
biology
we started uh adopting uh data-driven
approaches
and this i think this is a game changer
because once we have data we can
uh we can extract patterns and it's not
surprising that machine learning
is used uh talking about machine
learning it's also like biology it's
all different methods it's like whales
and elephants
but uh and they might be used in
different ways and
uh and uh different methods can be used
so for example for whales we
we're mostly looking at unsupervised
methods
that try to somehow fill in the blinds
in uh to try to predict for example the
the next uh the next clicks from the
previous ones
uh for plants from uh from lilac so they
understand that they are using uh
uh mainly uh supervised uh methods which
try to associate
certain sounds to certain behaviors uh
but i think the common denominators here
is really the data
and there was an at one of the talks in
the in the workshop was i think by
mikhail irani where she was actually
talking about how can you
get away with a little bit of data when
in the in the
in the area of vision where you have uh
pictures which have a lot of repetitions
so you sort of
harvest data from one image and that
brought up i think some interesting
questions also that the
the communications in whales and plants
i guess they're also some natural
communication but i don't know if
there's really patterns there
um i uh
i think it's so
fascinating all i can say is uh that i'm
in awe
of this exploration um i want to touch
back on this
issue that michael alluded to about
communication versus language
so uh some of my friends uh early on who
are not on this project
where i mentioned theoretical computer
scientists
mentioned the idea that we're looking
for
i incorrectly used the word language and
they were really up in arms they're
saying well
what is language and whales don't speak
to each other and
brought up a very interesting question
indeed
we have to be so careful in our language
not to use this term um what is language
it's i don't know that any one of us can
really weigh on that because it's not
our specialty
but it's an interesting question um and
if anybody wants to say anything about
the
language versus communication issue no
no we still have to
justify the use of the communication
term all the time
because we don't know yet
about the sounds emitted by the
they might be emitted passively it might
be
a physical response to other
processes but once the sounds are out
there
then someone might respond
so when exactly do you need to
wish to admit the sound to actively emit
the sound
for this to be considered a
communication so the questions that we
run into again and again
so i guess it brings us to a question is
there like a
an experiment one could run to be able
to distinguish whether
something is closer to a language rather
than a communication
i think michael you mentioned to me the
idea of
can we tell whether whales are talking
about an event that happened in the past
as a test for whether they are
abstracting and speaking in language
rather than just communication
i think it's so i think well i'm not an
expert so
take anything that i'm telling with a
grain of salt but i think even this is
is disputed what you are mentioning
the ability to talk about events in the
past this is what linguists call
displacement
so if you think of communication system
as a set of features
and you can uh you can argue which
features are present in animals and
which
features are uniquely human so people
have been arguing
based on certain experimental evidence
whether for example
uh you have displacement in animals and
there are
there are certain examples that that
could lead to this
belief so what chomsky and causers argue
that the unique
really the unique feature of of human
language is recursion the
ability to embed a phrase in a phrase in
a phrase in the phrase
making it infinitely rich and and
variety
and this is something that we would
probably be able to discover
uh by analyzing the large uh
data sets of uh whale by acoustic data
i would i would say that whether it is
language or not it is probably
uh not that important maybe for in some
disciplines it is extremely important i
think it's more
a semantic notion how do you call it i
think uh
to find what the complexity the code of
communication tries associated to
behaviors
find maybe some some pattern some
structure maybe some of it
is utilitarian because uh language has
probably evolved to convey certain
information
and uh maybe in humans it has evolved
beyond this and we can use language for
uh abstract things that probably have no
immediate
uh immediate utility uh so i don't know
what will we discover
to me the biggest disappoint
disappointed of this project will really
be if the whales are
dull and non-interesting and they they
just click and do
and don't really talk about anything but
i
i i i'm very uh doubtful that that will
be the case
i think we'll discover a lot of
beautiful things
yeah in fact communication is not
necessarily just acoustic i mean that is
something that
also came up in the workshop we had
people talking about other forms of
communication between
different um you know between animals
from different species
and as mentioned communication in terms
of color
and um and so forth
even in pheromones and scent and yeah
yeah it's such a
it's a broad thing it's interesting i as
the different science disciplines talk
about this there are certain trigger
words
um that i've just been learning to avoid
um and if you just say language and like
you make
you know people get happier um but i
think that's one of the
even scientists we speak different
languages among
among disciplines and that's one of the
i guess one of the
beautiful things about this project is
we're trying to speak a common
um language and understand each other so
then we can understand
these other things that are growing in
the forest or
swimming in the ocean so you know the
simons institute is
instituted for theory of computation
obviously this is not a theoretical
project
in fact very much but
what we do is develop algorithmic tools
we analyze them and
i am extremely uh also excited about the
idea that
all this method all that we're
developing the new algorithms the new
analysis methods which are applied to
whales or the plants or to
elephants or to bats you know uh will
have as a side effect essentially coming
up with new tools
new algorithmic methods and that's
always been the case and in a sense
you're looking for one thing
yet you're developing an entire field
of apparatus machinery
algorithms well it's also interesting i
think that you brought in babies
with celeste kid um you know too
in one sense it's like humans we
as babies we're we have this natural
ability of
of learning and start babbling and then
speaking and
and that just the just the types of
people that you
you brought together um for this to to
to really think among
all these different areas because the
the tools that are applied
in in humans or in plants or in bats or
in elephants
um they could they could all possibly in
the years ahead start
funneling together and like you said
coming up with
more pipelines that could better
understand outside life and then i guess
the hope would be to write then better
understand ourselves
always yeah
thank you guys and thank you lilach um
very much for coming to the workshop for
all the work you're doing
and also coming to this polylog
interview i'm very humbled to be part of
this group
thank you thank you
[Music]
you